pas de coup de tonnerre aux élections
régionales arrivé en tête au premier
tour le président socialiste sortant
allié aux écologistes a remporté son
ticket pour un troisième mandat françois
bonneau qui a devancé la droite de
nicolas forissier invité surprise à
cette seconde place
audrey champigny c'est l'image de cette
soirée du deuxième tour
l'arrivée triomphante de françois
bonneau a clamé dans le hall de l'hôtel
de région d'orléans
il était un peu plus de 20h30 le
président socialiste sortant sait déjà
qu'il a gagné
réélu pour un troisième mandat ps et
verts unis dans la victoire
donc oui ce soir très heureux de pouvoir
aborder cette nouvelle étape avec de
l'énergie et avec un rassemblement qui
nous a permis d'aller au delà de nous
mêmes c'est ça qui compte c'est pas ce
sont pas les divisions se sont pas les
chicayas qui compte véritablement c'est
de porter un projet qui soit à la
hauteur des défis
loin derrière la droite avec 22 73%
nicolas forissier se satisfait de sa
deuxième place et assume son choix ne
pas avoir fait alliance avec le modem de
marc fesneau
ça aurait été totalement
contre-productif
si nous avions eu je ne sais quel accord
je les ai toujours pensé je les dis à
marc fesneau était de gagner ce soir
je ne crois je ne crois pas je pense que
le rassemblement national aurait été
extrêmement 1 devant devant nous ce
n'est pas moi qui doit regretter c'est
peut-être monsieur forissier mais on va
pas pleurer sur le lait renversé les
choses ont été dites les choses ont été
faites il n'y a pas de volonté de se
rassembler je pense que quand on veut un
rassemblement on le perd dans les
conditions qui peut se faire
naturellement
en cas de fusion de listes ça n'a pas
été au rendez vous on peut le regretter
parce que les additions pourrait
peut-être faire des choses s'apaisent
choix qui a été fait enfin le grand
perdant de cette soirée c'est à coup sûr
le rn et son poulain aleksandar nikolic
malgré une 3e place avec ses 22 58%
le plus jeune des candidats de cette
élection n'aura pas réussi à mobiliser
son électorat mais comptent peser dans
l'hémicycle je continuerai à être
constructif aaron sera évidemment
méfiants et regardant sur les dérives
peut-être de l'extrême gauche qui sera
en partie aux manettes au sein de la
collectivité
l'installation du nouveau conseil
régional est prévu vendredi 2 juillet
françois bonneau devrait logiquement
retrouver son siège de président